so how does it feel to be here at the
streamys and to intro your girl can
Petrus I love Kim she is amazing a pop
princess she's just killing it and I'm
so proud of her and I'm here to support
her tonight and also my YouTube family
that's right yes you support her so much
and the fact that you were in her music
video I want it all what are the chances
we can get you another visual with her
or maybe she can be one of your music
videos she's actually writing a song for
me now so yes I'm really excited for
that
are you so are you working on a full
album and what can we expect when it
comes to music with you Paris I have two
songs coming out with nervo we're
shooting music video in the next couple
weeks and Benny Benassi and I are doing
a song together and I'm producing music
and just touring all around the world
it's just it's been a really exciting
year and I can't wait for 2020 this year
we also got this amazing music video
from you with Kim Kardashian she she
says you're responsible for her career
what does that make you feel I love her
and I'm so proud of her and her whole
family they are just girl bosses killing
it and it's just all about women
empowerment I love it
[Music]